the root of the problem is telling kids
who have no idea what they want to do
with their lives to make the biggest
financial decision of their future
before they have any real world
experience claim that this is what is
required right now in the modern
workplace and then promising that we are
going to bail them out let's start with
this elizabeth warren was recently
questioned by a dad regarding student
loans and having put his daughter
compare that to Ted Cruz when he was in
Iowa when he was talking about corn
subsidies and the scenario so you're
gonna hurt our industry here and he
explained to the guy by the end of it
the guy in ER said the corn seventies
might actually be bad for his farm
imagine if it's come back your spin no
laughing right that's the better way the
constituents face hey I saved for a long
time I'm the American dream I have a
family I put my daughter through college
I can't buy your vote and in creating a
new victim class and right now the
victim class extends to people who
willingly took on student loans so I'm
getting loose with the terms here we
create real victims who might the real
victims be like this father or people
like folks who work here on this team
who worked two three jobs to pay their
way through through school or went to
community colleges or went to trade
school or some people who work here who
actually didn't go to university and
instead gained workplace experience and
worked their way up those are the actual
victims because they will be double
footing the bill they saved their money
right they avoided the student loans or
they paid off their own student loans
and now you are asking them to pay your
student loans it's understand how it
seems compassionate at people hey these
folks are saddled with debt and we'll
get into that in a second and why that's
not necessarily accurate even let's
assume that student loans in its
predatory lending it's the bank's fault
it still wouldn't solve the issue in
forcing somebody else to pay that bill
twice okay so let's go through this idea
though the crisis because it's
predicates on the idea that there's a
crisis right now this is a huge claim
you see from current Democrats that
there's 1.4 trillion in student debt
right $35,000 on average per individual
I think we have it we have a clip on
this welcome back to Vell Chien rule
senator Bernie Sanders is joining others
in Congress to unveil a sweeping new
plan that when developing nations put
questions on this proposal
completely eliminate student debt in
this country and ends the absurdity of
sentencing an entire generation the
millennial generation to a lifetime of
caring for the crime of doing the right
thing 1.5 trillion in student loan debt
and this time we're gonna choose our
people right Philadelphia what do you
mean sours people
percent of the function to questions why
is Andrew yang wearing his hat up like
Ernest goes to can drive and second
there's be any more transparent with his
pandering all generation the Millennials
what about boomers this year Millennials
who undoubtedly will vote for me this is
something it's important to note it
sounds like a lot 1.4 trillion it's not
nothing
car loan debt in this country is about
1.2 trillion dollars and cars appreciate
way faster than education unless of
course it's a gender studies degree in
which case depreciate 100 percent once
you roll your fat angry feminist ass off
the lot let's go we're talking our car
payment mortgage loan debt by the way
that comes in at an average of over
$200,000 per person that's nine point
five trillion dollars Josh why isn't
that considered a crisis here's a quick
lesson for you and people got mad at
this week if you want everyone out there
okay uncle Stevens taken care of if you
want to build wealth
don't buy a new car ever right and to
other people if you want to go green
right you want to be environmentalist
don't buy a new car let's just say ever
it is better for you to buy an old 85
Bronco than that new Tesla it has to be
created and driven off the lot so that
you can have your rich white liberal
guilt status symbol I don't just don't
really someone always has to pay the
bill it's like daddy with health care in
pre-existing conditions what you're
doing is now you've astronomically
raised health care costs right we're
talking about premiums deductibles
that's because people who opted and by
the way most people who didn't have
health insurance chose not to have
health insurance when we crunch the
numbers so you can go back and search
that segment they could afford health
insurance particularly young people they
opted not to until they had a serious
condition well the whole point to buying
health care insurance is it's basically
creating a pool of lower risk so that
you can use it when you need it so the
people who bought health insurance
before the emergency arose that's why
they locked in lower rates then had to
pay a higher bill because everyone else
who didn't have that kind of forethought
is now joining into the same pool it
ends up harming people who've thought
ahead who planned responsibly you're not
always some people get some tough breaks
by the way tough break notifications
don't really work you have to hit
notification bell all mota fication
because Thank You YouTube and please do
consider joining up at a lot of credit
um slash mug Club mug Club you get
everything that is available unplaced TV
and this wonderful a niche mug in like
nineteen more shows of this per week
okay exactly its 478 all right here's
another point I think we need to get
feels like um if we're talking about who
it harms who does or who would rather a
student loan forgiveness who would that
reward right Bernie Sanders actually
uses this term you just talked about use
of the term punishing I believe right
now we should stop punishing people for
going to school we have a clip bottom
line is we should not be punishing
people for getting a higher education it
is time to hit the reset button under
the proposal that we introduced today
all student debt would be canceled in
six months well you know what Bernie
maybe you should be punished for being a
lifelong unemployed couchsurfing [ __ ]
who's never been gainfully employed
aside from suckling at the government's
teat maybe you a little bit forgiving
student debt it punishes those who
worked hard and everyone ended up like
we've talked yet the Iowa debt but who
does it reward
okay people think that if we forgive
student loans and this is again I
understand why people think it's
compassionate but the numbers do matter
they think that most of this money is
going to go to those who have a hard
time paying off their loans right that's
how Bernie presents it right a ton of
that would go to people who are making a
lot of money anyway so yes the average
will come back to that student debt is
around thirty five thousand dollars but
let's look at how its distributed I
think we have it let's look at a chart
we have it right here most of the people
if you look fall on the low end of that
spectrum well below thirty thousand yeah
and then you have students with
astronomical costs right they stretch
things out on the opposite end of the
spectrum so those on the high end you
see in this chart typically come from
families making over one hundred and
fourteen thousand dollars a year and
they go into careers like law and
dentistry so it takes some time to pay
off those loans but they're actually
living pretty comfortably a huge or I
should say a huge portion of these large
numbers that are being cited it's
actually evidence of a crisis that is
somewhat created by upper-class families
who take out loans to put their kids
into very lucrative career paths I mean
how much is law school I mean it can
range anywhere from if you're at certain
state programs
20,000 a year 250 or 60,000 a year all
told with the expenses so right exactly
but you're not gonna be destitute if you
go into law people by the way you have
problems paying off their loans it's
actually a pretty small group they tend
to have people who actually have a hard
time paying off the loans being settled
by debt tends to be less than $5,000
when you eliminate people who are going
to medical law school yeah where they
have a lot of student debt initially and
they pay it off quickly people who
long-term have problems paying it $5,000
that's a number that matters
so let's before we go to the idea of
federal government what could be a
personal solution for you right is there
a silver lining yeah there is it doesn't
require any federal intervention okay so
here are the steps you can take number
one go to a reasonable college or trade
school okay then number two choose a
major discipline that'll set you up for
a well paying job number three finish
your degree that's it that's it finish
your degree
statistically you'll be absolutely fine
again those people who have that debt if
$5,000 hard tempting most of them don't
finish but this brings me to point
number three everyone else you should
consider traceable trade schools have a
ton of advantages over four-year
colleges on average by the way they have
about 70% less debt twice the job
placement almost twice the starting
salary average debt 36,000 and a
four-year college we just went through
those numbers job placement about 50
percent average debt ten thousand
dollars for two-year trade school 100
percent average job placement with
almost twice the starting salary but
again we we market this idea of the
college experience which for many is
four years of glorified alcoholism
certainly yeah don't forget the victory
lap if they go for five like this you
don't need to do it and this does come
from a lot of intellectuals a lot of
politicians who place this value on an
elite university that is not reflected
in real world numbers I've had parents
be horrified when kemp's come up at live
shows until you give my son any advice I
said well what do you want to do and if
they say I want to be a fireman or no
it's great to it they say yeah I don't
know yet I said don't go to university
debt and I think it's very important to
we're talking about going to university
or whether you go to trade school do
choose your major wisely okay this is
another kind of solution that you can
all take into account here or not and
then ask Bernie to take my money to bail
you out fine but think about how you
make any other purchases right you just
go out and buy the most expensive car
you can afford do you
you buy the most expensive house you can
afford no financial adviser would say
that's what you should do
that is exactly what we do with
universities we tell kids apply to all
of the top schools meaning the most
expensive the most prestigious schools
that's usually what parents tell their
effort to see which one takes you in and
if we look at University Rankings based
on economic value added to students
lives not their status symbol not how
many people see the the the crest on
your jacket right yeah but how much
value it actually adds to students lives
here we can look at the metrics actually
with these numbers look at average
student salaries the employment rate if
students are employed in their
particular field of studies according to
that metric many of the top colleges
they're just public universities in
state schools yeah basically unless
you're planning on going to the Supreme
Court you don't need an Ivy League
university to be at the top of your
field people on the top of any of these
given fields there is no no correlation
between a specific school or degree from
that school and success now if you know
exactly what you want to do let's say
practice law or host a podcast where you
want to tell everyone that you practice
law bunch of yang to his credits talked
about how some somehow maybe cost should
be tied to those fields of education and
if you look at majors like I think it's
education like art he hit art history
ethnic studies things like that you know
things that are kind of useless that you
can learn on Google and two afternoons
they're not high earning fields right
but they require a comparable amount of
student loan debt right on the other end
the majors that have the highest
earnings to debt ratio are stem degrees
right which is science technology
engineering mathematics masters in
humanities from Stanford is like having
a brand new Maserati in your driveway
it's a it's a modern status symbol and
it costs you a lot of money for a piece
of Maserati yes your mozzarel
mother all Maseratis no Maserati
sponsorship here
no not have to pick their competitor
also BMW just take me off your list I
don't like your cars I'm not gonna
happen
yeah this goes back to if you have a
clear plan of what you're majoring what
the best school is for you I don't I
don't want to discourage you you should
ask you for that absolutely but keep in
mind twenty to fifty percent of students
they enter school is undecided and then
most of them not so most of them end up
changing their major again step one you
want to fix go to a reasonable school
step two don't major in worthless [ __ ]
step three finish your degree and you
will avoid this problem this is a
brilliant ploy right you tell people
young people Millennials as Bernie
Sanders said his voting base you tell
them that they are the victim of some
predatory system of lending right you
encourage them to saddle themselves with
more debt in attending universities that
they can't afford often pursuing degrees
that guarantee all but guarantee an
inability to pay off that debt not to
mention by the way you are encouraging
young people to make arguably the
largest financial decision of their
lives now before they graduate high
school because they're already applying
you further encourage you further
incentivize this behavior with grants
and scholarships from the government
like you said which also leads to two
simultaneously hyper inflates right the
cost of education overall and then you
bribe the voters who followed your
instructions explicitly by promising to
bail them out with other people's money
and this is something I hear a lot you
hear appeals and well why shouldn't we
bail since we bailed out the banks how
about we bail out nothing how about we
don't bail out Goldman Sachs or the Afro
lesbian Studies major you hear these
songs they hit get to any politics that
you hear on the right as well it while
they're living it up on Wall Street
they're shutting Detroit down shut them
both down shut all of it down I'm not
looking for as a Bear Stearns Goldman
Sachs Bear Stearns
they're stern bears which there's bear
and there's bull correct Bear Stearns in
the bank bear market bull market you can
see I don't know economics I just make
it rain but we should not be bailing out
any of these people what's the root of
the problem here and again I want to
hear from you I understand that people
on both sides are compassionate the root
of the problem is telling kids who have
no idea what they want to do with their
lives to make the biggest financial
decision of their future before they
have any real
experience claim that this is what is
required right now in the modern
workplace and to have self-esteem we're
also by the way tying up children tying
up young people's self-worth with the
degree they have with a sheet of paper
to tell people how important they are
and then promising that we are going to
bail them out it doesn't work it has not
worked it will not work the solution is
not to bail people out the solution is
that everybody start taking personal
responsibility and making better
decisions for yourself what is that let
me go through it one more time ok don't
waste money going to an expensive
university if you don't have to don't
get a useless degree and finish if you
do go to school congratulations I just
saved you 1.4 trillion dollars in a
national bailout if you enjoyed this
video subscribe or hit the notification
bell or watch the full show that is
playing in a box I believe on this
screen next to me now if you don't like
it because you disagree with my stance
on student loans I understand and I want
to hear from you in the comment section
and I would also like you to send an
envelope of unmarked bills to p.o box
405 six in Schenectady New York
to do your part again that's P o box
well I'll put it down on screen because
I I won't remember the number that I
just made up